J'ai trouvé une cohorte de jeunes femmes de plus de 25 ans
dont le corps s'effondrait.
Il était frappant de constater que personne ne nous prenait
vraiment au sérieux.
J'ai entendu l'histoire d'une femme
souffrant de sclérodermie,
qu'on a ignorée pendant des années.
Le retard de prise en charge
a tellement endommagé son œsophage
qu'elle ne pourra plus jamais remanger.
Une femme qui souffrait d'un cancer de l'ovaire
à qui on a dit que c'était juste une ménopause précoce.
Une amie de fac,
dont la tumeur cérébrale a été prise pour de l'anxiété pendant des années.
Voici pourquoi je suis inquiète :
depuis les années 50, la prévalence de bien des maladies auto-immunes
a doublé, voire triplé.
45% des patients à qui on finit par diagnostiquer
une maladie auto-immune
sont initialement accusés d'hypocondrie.
Comme pour l'hystérie d'autrefois, il s'agit de sexisme
et de qui nous voulons bien croire.
70% des cas de maladie auto-immune sont des femmes,
et dans le cas de certaines maladies, le chiffre monte à 90%.
Bien que ces maladies affectent bien plus les femmes,
elles ne sont pas les seules concernées.
L'EM touche des enfants et des millions d'hommes.
Et comme un patient me l'a dit,
ça va dans les deux sens -
on dit aux femmes qu'elles exagèrent,
et aux hommes qu'ils doivent s'endurcir, se blinder.
Les hommes ont peut-être encore plus de mal à obtenir un diagnostic.
Mon cerveau n'est plus ce qu'il était.
Il y a aussi du positif :
malgré tout, j'ai encore de l'espoir.
Tant de maladies étaient autrefois considérées comme psychologiques
jusqu'à ce que la science découvre leur mécanisme biologique.
Les épileptiques pouvaient être internés de force
avant que l'EEG ne puisse mesurer les anomalies électriques cérébrales.
La sclérose en plaques pouvait être prise pour de l'hystérie
avant que le scanner et l'IRM ne découvrent les lésions cérébrales.
Récemment, nous pensions
que seul le stress causait les ulcères de l'estomac
avant de découvrir qu'H.pylori était le coupable.
L'EM n'a jamais bénéficié du même effort de recherche
que d'autres maladies
mais tout ça est en train de changer.
En Allemagne, des chercheurs ont trouvé des preuves d'auto-immunité,
et au Japon, d'inflammation cérébrale.
Aux Etats-Unis, des chercheurs de Stanford ont trouvé des anomalies
du métabolisme énergétique
qui sont 16 fois supérieures à la normale.
Et en Norvège, des chercheurs mènent un essai clinique
sur un médicament anti-cancer qui peut entraîner une rémission totale.
Ce qui me donne aussi de l'espoir,
c'est la résilience des patients.
Sur internet, on s'est réunis
et on s'est raconté notre vécu.
On a dévoré la recherche existante.
On a fait des expériences sur nous-mêmes.
On a endossé le rôle de chercheur, de médecin
parce qu'on n'avait pas d'autre choix.
Et très lentement, j'ai progressé
jusqu'à ce que finalement, les bons jours,
je sois capable de sortir de chez moi.
J'étais encore forcée de faire des choix absurdes.
Aujourd'hui, je sors un peu dans le jardin ou bien je me lave les cheveux.
Mais ça m'a redonné espoir.
Mon corps était malade, c'est tout.
Et peut-être qu'avec le bon traitement, je pourrais un jour aller mieux.
Je me suis unie à d'autres patients du monde entier
et ensemble, on se bat.
Nous avons changé le vide en quelque chose de merveilleux,
mais tout ça ne suffit pas.
Je ne sais toujours pas si je pourrai un jour reprendre la course à pied
ou même marcher,
ou bouger comme j'en rêve la nuit.
Mais je suis si reconnaissante de tout le chemin parcouru.
La route est longue,
on va mieux,
puis moins bien,
mais mon état s'améliore un peu de jour en jour.
Je me souviens de tout ce temps que j'ai passé coincée au fond de mon lit,
quand je n'avais pas vu la lumière du jour depuis des mois.
Je croyais que j'allais mourir comme ça.
Et pourtant, me voici, aujourd'hui
avec vous,
et ça, c'est un vrai miracle.
Je ne sais pas ce qui serait arrivé si j'avais été moins chanceuse,
si j'étais tombée malade avant internet,
si je n'avais pas trouvé ma tribu.
Je me serais déjà probablement suicidée,
comme tant d'autres avant moi.
Combien de vies aurions-nous pu sauver, il y a des années,
si nous avions posé les bonnes questions ?
Combien pourrait-on en sauver aujourd'hui
si l'on décidait de changer les choses ?
Même quand on découvrira la véritable cause de ma maladie,
si nous ne changeons pas nos institutions, notre culture,
nous recommencerons avec une autre maladie.
Vivre avec cette maladie m'a appris
que la science et la médecine sont fondamentament humaines.
Les médecins, les scientifiques et les décideurs
ne sont pas immunisés contre les biais cognitifs
qui nous affectent tous.
Il faut nuancer notre vision de la santé des femmes.
Notre système immunitaire est tout autant un enjeu féministe
que le reste de notre corps.
Il faut écouter les patients,
et être capable de dire : « Je ne sais pas. »
Oser dire « Je ne sais pas », c'est formidable.
C'est là que les découvertes naissent.
Si nous réussissons à envisager
l'étendue de notre ignorance,
alors, plutôt que de la craindre,
nous pourrons accueillir cette incertitude avec émerveillement.
Merci.